WOULD SAY.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THE PRESS SPENT
THE ENTIRE DAY AS YOU
WATCHED REPORTING ON
BUZZFEED'S DISHONEST REPORT.
IMPEACHMENT, INDICTMENT,
MAYBE A WAVES OF INDICTMENT.
MAYBE EVERYBODY GOES TO
JAIL.
LOOKS LIKE NOT AT LEAST FOR
ENOUGH TO.
ETHAN IS A PROGRESSIVE RADIO
HOST IN CALIFORNIA AND
FREQUENT GUEST OF THE SHOW.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
I MEAN, ETHAN, COULD THIS
BE -- LET ME REPHRASE THE
QUESTION AND MAKE IT A
STATEMENT.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF PEOPLE
BELIEVING WHAT THEY WANTED
TO BELIEVE.
>> WELL, I THINK THERE WAS
SOME OF THAT HOWEVER, I WANT
TO SAY SOMETHING RIGHT UP
FRONT.
IT'S AN INTERESTING AND ODD
DAY WHEN I AGREE AS MUCH
WITH DAN BONGINO AS MAYBE
EVEN MORE SO THAN GUY BENSON
RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE, DAN IS RIGHT.
WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME TRUST
AND FAITH IN JOURNALISTS.
AND THERE IS A PROBLEM RIGHT
NOW WHERE JOURNALISTS WANT
TO BE OPINION HOST.
AND THEY BLUR THE LINE
BECAUSE IT'S EXCITING
SHARING YOUR OPINION.
YOU AND I LOVE SHARING OUR
OPINION.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO BASE IT
ON FACTS AND HAVE FAITH.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO PARSE THE
WORDS OF THE ATTORNEY HERE,
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL, HE
DIDN'T SAY FALSE, 234069
ACCURATE ACTUALLY IN A LEGAL
CONTEST IS VERY DIFFERENT
FROM FALL.
WE DON'T KNOW AND IN SLIGHT
DEFERENCE TO BUZZFEED AT
THIS POINT BECAUSE I'M
DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED IN THIS
NEWS COMING OUT BUT SOME
SLIGHT DEFERENCE TO BUZZFEED
WHICH IS HEY, LET'S FIGURE
OUT WHAT ISN'T ACCURATE
BEFORE WE THROW ALL OF IT
OUT.
MAYBE THERE WERE PIECES THAT
WERE RIGHT.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> WHAT PIECES WEREN'T.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS WRONG
ABOUT IT?
>> Tucker: LOOK.
YOU MAKE A FAIR POINT.
THERE'S A LOT WE DON'T KNOW
AND I AM NOT GOING TO GET
OVER MY SKIS AND SPECULATING
ABOUT WHAT DID OR DID NOT
HAPPEN.
>> I DON'T THINK RUSSIA IS
THE PRIMARY THREAT WE FACE
GOING FORWARD.
THAT'S OBVIOUS.
SPECIFICS IN THIS CASE ARE
UNKNOWN TO ME.
YOU ARE RIGHT WE ARE GOING
TO FIND OUT A LOT OF STUFF
WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT TO HAVE SOMEONE WHO
WOULD KNOW, THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL TAKE THIS
EXTRAORDINARY STEP OF
REFUTING AT LEAST TO SOME
DEGREE THE STORY TELLS YOU
MUST HAVE BEEN PRETTY WRONG.
WHY ELSE WOULD HE DO THIS
BECAUSE IS HE COVERING FOR
TRUMP?
PROBABLY NOT, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
ASTOUNDING AS I WAS COMING
IN AND SEEING THIS NEWS COME
ACROSS, I MIGHT -- MY JAW
MIGHT HAVE BEEN DROPPING
OPEN BECAUSE MUELLER DOESN'T
TALK.
HIS TEAM DOESN'T TALK.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
>> FOR HIM TO COME OUT AND
TALK RIGHT NOW IT'S A HUGE
DEAL.
>> Tucker: I'M SORRY, I AM
BEING TOLD WE ARE OUT OF
TIME.